you know women they can't even get the
[__] luggage out of the overhead bin
but then when their kid is trapped in
the car upside down all the sudden this
[__] could flip a car yeah where the
[__] did that come from I had never seen
that I've seen that story that's always
women no men it's crazy you know yep
obviously because we could drive it's
easy to be on the ground and go oh there
is no God there's no God at all the
second that wheel comes off the [__]
tarmac I'm looking for a yarmulke Jesus
Buddha Allah
maybe not Allah kun all got a joke one
of the abd Caesar he's like listen if my
girl don't care bro bro might care about
that all right
sorry Kunal I care about that right now
how old are you guys just turn 18 si let
me everybody stops guys trying to get
locked up over here right if she's 18
you go 18 18 and legal don't be like
just turn you're not the [__]
brazzers title that you just gave me for
her so I'm on like a later thing a later
squat and like I'll be like get down
just fine but then I'll try to get it up
yeah and you know that part between
where the lowest you can go is and right
where you can push through yeah in order
for me to get through there I gotta go
like just turn 18 yesterday
[Laughter]
fresh as they come so what was it like
[__] when she was 17 but so you
really don't want kids at all is that
your boyfriend right there your brother
okay
sorry mate did you just hit on me
[Music]
is this your this not your boyfriend
that's your first day you can't hit on
me during the first day that's [__] up
now you do have the big-ass titties I'm
not a lotta women let you grab them by
the [__] checks out I don't don't get
me wrong I know there's women in here
who are like that's [__] up that's a
[__] I would never allow that and to
you I would say you've never met a
billionaire
[Music]
that's predatory behavior so I'm gonna
lay all my weight on top of a woman and
then thrust inside her not me okay I lay
on my back I put my hands underneath my
budgets
like a strong feminist Ally
we did not ride you know how many
billionaires there are in the world it's
like a hundred any one of them could
grab my dick let Bill Gates walk up to
me right now grab my dick I'll grab his
wrist and hold that [__] down she has an
email called pretty dicks way at
gmail.com okay well people send dick
pics okay every day she's checking his
email every day for four years I've
looked at it three times you know I've
looked at it three times
cuz holy [__]
part I got the most gross feet I want
you guys see why your big toe got black
face cool man thanks for asking bro
hater no not here in [__] Australia
trying to get some [__] now you make me
feel all guilty
I got a 38 year old who's barren ready
to go you know I met Jesus can't invite
these [__] Indians anywhere dude I
almost said go back to your country let
me tell you something I just had a sed
test so I had to celebrate yeah by
[__] Rory laughter John now fool you
got keep shooting these girls will take
eyelashes and put them on top of their
already existing eyelashes is that not
[__]
you're like girls family is giving you
[__] you ever look at them like you know
I busting your sister what are you gonna
say to me you know at any point in time
I can shut down the whole dinner I win
you show love through love we don't do
that we shall love through sacrifice so
a lot of times we'll be loving you and
you don't even know
32 good beer you got any kids no kids
you got kids how many one kid and you
were gonna let two guys [__] you're a
babysitter [__] it's you and nanny you
have me he took you from Manny to
millionare and you expect fidelity [__]
earn your fertility [__] bring
something to the table [__] how dare
you [__]
take a gulf come on [__] - this man's
cards where all you did this is how the
[__] bottle talk a [__]